If you followed the previous step,
you saw that text like this
can turn into text like this.
And even though you don't
know how this happened,
you probably can guess that these tags
here had something to do with it.
Somehow the computer was interpreting
those things differently
than how a person would.
And that is a huge idea.
Because before this experience
you probably didn't even
know what you didn't know
about making web pages.
And now, even though you don't really
know how to talk to a computer,
you may have some understanding of
what talking to a computer even means.
You're beginning to know,
what you don't know.
And may even have a basic intuition for
what coding even is.
Because coding a computer,
is just telling a computer
what you want it to do, by writing text,
in a way it can understand.